Il y a 50 ans, le 4 février 1945, Churchill,
Roosevelt et Staline se retrouvaient à Yalta.
Depuis un demi siècle, le nom de Yalta est attaché
à un mythe, le mythe du partage de l'Europe.
Jusqu'à la chute du mur de Berlin en 1989
on a parlé de l'Europe de Yalta.
Mais entre le mythe et l'histoire, le fossé est large
que nous allons explorer tout au long de cette émission.
Nous allons raconter ce qui s'est vraiment
passé entre les trois grands à la fin de la guerre,
De la conférence de Yalta en février à celle de Potsdam en juillet.
Nous sommes à Berlin, longtemps symbole de la
division d'une ville, d'un pays, de l'Europe.
Nous arrivons maintenant au Cecilienhof où
s'est tenue la conférence de Potsdam.
Tout en visitant ce lieu historique en compagnie de Robert Frank, spécialiste de l'histoire des relations internationales,
Nous allons plonger dans ces six mois où s'achève la
Deuxième Guerre mondiale et se dessine l'avenir du monde.
Et d'abord la situation militaire au début de 1945.
Au printemps 1944, le rouleau compresseur soviétique repousse
les troupes allemandes en Ukraine et en Biélorussie.
Au début de l'été, l'Armée rouge reprend Minsk.
Les Soviétiques, en quelques semaines d'une poussée
décisive, avancent de 600 kilomètres jusqu'à la Vistule.
Le 23 juillet, les Russes pénètrent en Pologne
et libèrent Lublin trois jours plus tard.
Ils installent dans la ville un Comité de libération
nationale dominé par les communistes et dirigé par Bierut.
La totalité du territoire de l'U.R.S.S. est libérée.
Staline fête l'événement à sa manière en organisant à
Moscou un gigantesque défilé de prisonniers allemands.
On ne peut mieux symboliser la défaite
de l'orgueilleux envahisseur.
À l'autre bout de l'Europe, au moment même
où se développe l'offensive soviétique,
Les Alliés débarquent en Normandie.
Ils piétinent un temps dans le bocage
avant de foncer vers la capitale française.
Le 25 août, Paris fête sa libération.
Trois semaines auparavant, le 5 août 44, Varsovie s'est insurgée.
Alors que l'Armée rouge reste cantonnée sur la rive
droite de la Vistule, aux portes de Varsovie,
La résistance polonaise, qui se reconnaît
dans le gouvernement en exil de Londres,
A déclenché l'insurrection contre l'occupant allemand.
Les partisans polonais livrent une bataille
héroïque, mais le 2 octobre, doivent capituler.
Les Soviétiques n'ont pas bougé.
Les Allemands rasent la ville où on dénombre 50 000 victimes.
La résistance polonaise non communiste n'existe plus.
Staline a préféré laisser les Allemands l'écraser
plutôt que de l'aider à prendre le pouvoir.
Plus au sud, l'Armée rouge progresse rapidement.
En août, elle entre en Roumanie et prend Bucarest. Les Roumains signent un armistice et se retournent contre l'Allemagne.
La Bulgarie n'avait pas déclaré la guerre à l'Union
soviétique, est envahie au début de septembre.
Un soulèvement populaire éclate qui porte au pouvoir un gouvernement de Front patriotique dominé par les communistes.
Le 18 août, l'armée rouge entre dans Sofia.
La guerre des Partisans bat son plein en Grèce et en Yougoslavie,
Où toujours en septembre, les Russes font leur jonction
avec les partisans de Tito, dans une ambiance enthousiaste.
Hitler, alors, n'a pas d'autre choix que d'ordonner à ses
armées d'évacuer la Grèce et le sud de la Yougoslavie.
La Wehrmacht se replie sur une ligne
défensive dont Budapest est le pivot.
Ainsi, en quelques semaines, l'Armée rouge a réalisé
une avancée importante dans l'Europe balkanique.
Churchill s'en inquiète et fait débarqué
des troupes anglaises en Grèce, en octobre.
Mais le Premier ministre britannique sait
qu'il ne peut s'opposer militairement aux Russes.
Il préfère négocier directement avec Staline.
L'ambassadeur de Grande-Bretagne, Clark Kerr,
celui des États-Unis, Averell Harriman,
Et Viatcheslav Molotov, le ministre des Affaires étrangères
de l'URSS, sont venus saluer le départ de Churchill,
Qui vient de passer une semaine en tractation avec Staline.
La présence d'Harriman n'est de pure forme car cette conférence
de Moscou s'est déroulée sans la participation américaine.
Au cours de ces rencontres, Staline et Churchill ont conclu
ce qu'on appellera plus tard l'accord des pourcentages.
Griffonné par Churchill sur une feuille de papier,
il prévoit une influence soviétique à 90% en Roumanie,
À 80% en Bulgarie à 50, puis 80% en Hongrie,
un partage à 50-50 en Yougoslavie,
Et enfin une influence à 90% pour les Occidentaux en Grèce.
Churchill relate ainsi la scène dans ses mémoires,
J'ai poussé le papier devant Staline,
à qui la traduction en fut faite.
Il prit son crayon et traça un gros trait en matière d'approbation.
Le papier rayé de bleu demeurait au centre de la table.
Je dis finalement ne trouvez vous pas un peu cynique
que nous ayons l'air d'avoir réglé ces problèmes,
Dont dépendent le sort de millions d'hommes
d'une façon aussi cavalière, brûlons ce papier.
Non, gardez le, dit Staline.
Churchill a obtenu les mains libres en Grèce où commence une guerre civile entre le gouvernement royal et la résistance communiste.
Les Britanniques peuvent intervenir et réprimer
les communistes sans que Staline réagisse.
À l'autre bout de la planète, dans le Pacifique, les
Américains livrent une guerre terrible contre les Japonais.
À l'automne 44, MacArthur se lance à la reconquête des Philippines.
Devant des adversaires déterminés à mourir sur
place, la progression des GI est difficile.
L'acharnement des combats montre bien que dans cette
partie du monde, la victoire n'est pas acquise.
L'archipel japonais est encore loin. Les experts américains n'envisagent pas de l'atteindre avant de longs mois.
Entre les deux guerres, celle d'Europe et
celle d'Asie, le décalage chronologique est grand.
Il pèsera sur les réflexions de Roosevelt.
En décembre 44 sur le front occidental de l'Europe, alors que les Alliés sont aux portes de l'Allemagne, le Reich résiste toujours.
Hitler place ses derniers espoirs dans les armes nouvelles,
comme l'avion à réaction dont les essais sont prometteurs.
Et puis c'est la surprise. Hitler joue son dernier coup de dés.
Le 15 décembre, il lance 25 divisions de
Panzer dans la contre offensive des Ardennes,
À l'endroit le plus faible du dispositif allié.
Au début, l'avance des blindés allemands
est rapide, mais Bastogne résiste.
Au début de janvier, la situation se retourne.
Les alliés reprennent leur progression.
Mais cet ultime sursaut de la Wehrmacht
a perturbé les plans d'Eisenhower,
Et retardé de plusieurs semaines l'avance des Anglo-Saxons.
Car au moment même où ils se battent dans la boue des Ardennes,
sur le front de l'Est, l'offensive soviétique repart.
L'armée rouge franchit enfin la Vistule et
pénètre dans les ruines de Varsovie.
Les Russes s'installent dans la capitale polonaise,
le gouvernement qui leur est favorable.
À la fin de janvier, toute la Pologne est libérée. Les maréchaux Koniev et Joukov sont sur l'Oder, ultime défense avant Berlin.
Ils massent des forces considérables en vue de la dernière ruée.
À la veille de Yalta, l'Armée rouge est à
80 kilomètres de la capitale du Troisième Reich.
Robert Frank, quand Staline arrive à Yalta sur un plan militaire vis à vis des Alliés, il est dans une position de force écrasante.
Il y a un rapport de force en sa faveur
d'une façon écrasante en effet,
L'Armée rouge a pénétré la plus grande partie de
l'Europe centrale et orientale, on l'a vu dans le film,
Elle rentre même en Allemagne et elle
s'apprête à entamer la bataille de Berlin.
Voilà c'est-à-dire que Staline peut prendre Berlin quand...
Tout à fait, disons que ça va prendre du temps,
mais disons qu'il est en position.
Au contraire, du côté des Occidentaux,
ils n'ont pas encore franchi le Rhin.
Ils ne le feront qu'un mois après Yalta.
Donc il y a une dissymétrie tout à fait notable.
Est-ce que sur un plan psychologique, disons,
les alliés Roosevelt et Churchill,
Estiment que vis à vis de l'effort de l'Armée
rouge et des sacrifices de l'Armée rouge,
Ils ont une sorte de dette d'ailleurs ?
Oui une dette morale certaine. Premier point l'Armée rouge
a retenu la plus grande partie des forces allemandes,
Les trois quarts, à peu près.
Les trois quarts, ce qui a facilité le débarquement en
Normandie quelques mois plus tôt en juin.
Mais quand on parle du débarquement, il faut toujours penser
que de l'autre côté, il y avait les trois quarts des forces.
Et donc dans une certaine mesure, les Soviétiques,
indirectement, participe au débarquement, si on peut dire.
D'autre part, le nombre de morts,
des millions de morts du côté soviétique.
Au fond, l'Union soviétique n'a pas
eu le choix. Elle a été attaquée,
Elle a fait ensuite sa contre offensive à partir de l'été 43.
Les Anglo américains, ils ont le choix et ce
second front, réclamé depuis longtemps par Staline,
N'a été vraiment installé en Europe que,
du point de vue massif, en juin 44.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il s'agissait d'économiser des vies américaines, des vies britanniques, ce qui est tout à fait louable.
Mais évidemment du point de vue de Staline,
on retrouve donc une autre dissymétrie,
Et Staline, bien entendu, leur fait comprendre.
Et ça c'est un argument qui va...
Alors ils se rencontrent pourquoi à Yalta en Crimée,
Churchill, Roosevelt et Staline ? Pourquoi ils se voient ?
Bah ils ont beaucoup de choses à se dire, ils ont beaucoup de choses à dire d'abord parce que la guerre n'est pas finie,
Il faut parler donc des opérations militaires futures,
donc à parler encore de stratégie.
Ils ne ce sont pas vus depuis longtemps, à trois du mois.
À Téhéran, en novembre, décembre 1943.
Ça fait plus d'un an,
Ça fait plus d'un an. Alors c'est vrai, Churchill et
Staline se sont vus en octobre 44 à Moscou,
Ils ont discuté entre eux, et Roosevelt n'y était pas.
Il était en pleine campagne électorale pour sa quatrième élection.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça que Yalta se passe en février,
c'est qu'il a fallu attendre la réélection de Roosevelt.
Exactement, donc ça a un peu décalé la grande conférence
à trois et Roosevelt n'est pas forcément content,
De ce que Churchill et Staline se sont dit.
Donc il veut être là, il veut une conférence le plus vite possible,
Pour que l'Amérique puisse faire peser de son
poids son influence dans le règlement de la guerre.
Parce qu'ils ne sont pas évidemment tous
les trois sur la même longueur d'onde,
Et chacun arrive là avec un objectif bien précis.
Churchill, il vient à Yalta, il veut quoi ? Il veut obtenir quoi ?
L'Angleterre a résisté héroïquement depuis 1940, elle a
un but relativement simple, c'est maintenir sa grandeur,
Et la grandeur, c'est l'Empire et
l'Empire, c'est la Méditerranée,
Il y a donc des enjeux méditerranéens à défendre.
Pour cette raison, en octobre 1944, à Moscou, dans
l'accord des pourcentages proposés par Churchill,
Ce qui lui importe le plus, c'est d'avoir l'influence prédominante en Grèce,
D'où d'ailleurs le débarquement britannique
en Grèce contre les communistes.
C'est à la suite de ce marchandage que Staline
lui laisse les mains libres en Grèce.
Et Staline ne réagit pas...
Quand l'armée britannique écrase les communistes Grecs.
Il obtient donc 50% en Yougoslavie.
Et au fond, le reste, c'est le continent ça intéresse le terrien.
On a vraiment une discussion de maquignons
entre un marin, Churchill, et le terrien Staline.
Alors, Staline, lui, il arrive là avec quel objectif ?
Alors lui, il a une vision vraiment européenne.
Je ne dirai pas que c'est le plus européen des trois,
mais disons qu'il y a un horizon presque plus limité,
Ce n'est pas l'Empire britannique sur
lequel le soleil ne se couche jamais,
Ce n'est pas la vision mondiale non plus de Roosevelt, c'est la sécurité de l'URSS avant tout en Europe centrale et orientale,
Et cette sécurité, ça peut presque être
symbolisé par le nom d'un pays, la Pologne.
Ça se passe par la Pologne.
Avoir une zone de sécurité, faire en sorte que le cordon sanitaire qui avait été imposé à l'Union soviétique entre les 2 guerres,
Soit retourner, que l'URSS soit entourée
non pas de pays ennemis, mais de pays amis.
Est-ce qu'en plus il y a une arrière pensée à savoir que
cette zone de sécurité militaire pourraient être ensuite...
Voilà qui a une organisation politique, à savoir
une influence communiste. C'est bien possible.
Disons que Staline est un homme roué, prudent, qui a toujours
deux fers au feu. Sécurité d'abord, sa priorité numéro un.
Et après tout, si le rapport de force
fait que ça aille plus loin, il le ferait.
Et Roosevelt, le dernier donc il vient là
avec une vision plus planétaire.
Voilà, c'est vraiment lui qui a la vision mondiale.
Alors deux choses, sa vision d'abord,
c'est non pas partager l'Europe ou le monde,
Et effectivement, ce maquignonnage typique de
la diplomatie européenne, Roosevelt n'en veut pas.
Il ne faut pas oublier que ça l'a même exaspéré.
Pour lui, à la rigueur, ce qu'il faut faire, c'est partager le gouvernement du monde, c'est-à-dire gouverner ensemble,
Et il fait confiance en Staline, il pense
que les trois grands peuvent le faire.
C'est sa vision idéaliste de
l'organisation du monde après la guerre.
C'est une vision idéaliste et pour lui, ce monde doit être gouverné par quatre gendarmes, peut-être cinq si son accepte la France,
Et à travers la nouvelle organisation
internationale, à savoir l'ONU.
Quand même, sur un plan militaire, il a un objectif
précis, c'est la guerre contre le Japon.
Il a un gros problème. Il a un gros problème qui est le suivant, c'est qu'il sait, lui, que la guerre mondiale n'est pas terminée,
Elle est sur le point de se terminer
en Allemagne, mais pas dans le Pacifique,
L'état-major, lui, dit il faut encore plusieurs mois, voire un
an de guerre, peut-être 500 000 morts du côté américain.
C'est vrai que pour nous Occidentaux, on
a l'impression que la guerre se termine,
Avec la libération de Paris ou la capitulation allemande.
- Mais pas du tout !
- Pas du tout, oui.
Et là, c'est très important. Lui, pourtant idéaliste, l'est pas uniquement puisqu'il a quand même fait préparer la bombe atomique,
Mais sa faiblesse, c'est qu'il ne sait
pas quand elle sera opérationnelle.
Donc il lui faut absolument l'intervention de l'URSS dans la guerre contre le Japon, d'autant plus, qu'il ne veut pas laisser à l'URSS,
Le temps d'être maître de l'Europe au
cas où lui et les Britanniques seraient enlisés,
Enfin si les Américains et les Britanniques
seraient enlisés dans la guerre du Pacifique,
Donc ne pas laisser le temps à Staline, ne pas
laisser les mains libres à Staline.
On a vu les objectifs des uns et des autres,
Maintenant on va voir à Yalta comment ça va se
passer sur le terrain, autour du tapis vert.
Voir ce qu'ils auront obtenu.
Churchill, Roosevelt et Staline se sont mis d'accord
pour se retrouver à Yalta, station balnéaire de Crimée.
C'est dans le palais Livadia où est logée la délégation
américaine, que se déroule les débats entre les trois grands.
Le 4 février 1945, Staline a envoyé son conseiller
Gromyko accueillir ses invités à l'aéroport de Saki.
L'avion de Churchill se pose le premier.
20 minutes plus tard, Roosevelt atterrit.
La première séance plénière s'ouvre à 17h,
le jour même, autour d'une immense table ronde.
D'entrée, le général soviétique Antonov dresse
un tableau de la situation militaire.
Il confirme que Berlin est sous la menace des canons russes,
mais prévoit que la bataille finale sera très dure.
Pour les anglo-saxons, le général Marshall
expose l'état du front occidental.
Il ne prévoit pas que les troupes alliées
puissent atteindre le Rhin avant mars.
Staline comprend qu'Eisenhower ne pourra
pas menacer Berlin avant deux mois.
Au lieu de se lancer immédiatement dans une attaque coûteuse
contre la capitale du Reich, Staline, puisqu'il a le temps,
Préfère utiliser ce délai et consacrer ses forces à
libérer la Hongrie et la Tchécoslovaquie.
Ainsi, la conduite même de la guerre esquisse
déjà la future carte politique de l'Europe.
Le lendemain, 5 février, l'ordre du jour de la seconde
réunion est consacré au sort de l'Allemagne vaincue.
Staline souhaite un démembrement, une division
en quatre ou cinq parties.
Churchill est réticent, ne voulant pas, selon ses propres termes, régler en 80 minutes le sort de 80 millions d'hommes et de femmes.
La question est renvoyée à plus tard.
Staline réclame également des réparations, il souhaite que
80% de l'industrie lourde allemande soit transférée en URSS,
Afin de reconstruire son pays dévasté, il
réclame des milliards de dollars.
Un deuxième grand sujet est alors abordé à
la séance plénière du 8 février,
La question de la Pologne, de ses frontières et de son gouvernement.
Les trois grands s'entendent pour fixer la frontière
entre la Pologne et l'URSS sur la ligne Curzon.
Staline récupère donc des territoires qui
appartenaient à l'ancienne Pologne.
En compensation, la conférence décide d'un accroissement de la Pologne vers l'ouest, c'est-à-dire au détriment de l'Allemagne.
Mais où faire passer cette nouvelle frontière ?
Staline propose la Neisse, affluent de l'Oder.
Mais il y a deux rivières qui portent ce nom,
une Neisse orientale et une Neisse occidentale.
La décision définitive est renvoyée à plus tard.
Mais le déplacement de la Pologne de l'après
guerre vers l'ouest est bien entériné à Yalta.
Reste alors le problème du gouvernement polonais.
Churchill, pressé par les Polonais en exil à Londres, répugne
à reconnaître le gouvernement prosoviétique de Varsovie.
Staline rétorque, cinglant, le gouvernement du comité de Lublin,
Est aussi démocratique que le gouvernement
provisoire du général de Gaulle,
Et qu'il soit reconnu est pour moi, une
question d'honneur et de sécurité.
Roosevelt, conciliateur, obtient de Staline que des élections libres et à bulletins secrets aient lieu dans les deux mois.
Il précise "Je veux qu'elle soit comme la femme
de César, qu'elle ne puisse être soupçonnée".
Ces élections n'auront jamais lieu.
Enfin, et c'est le plus important pour l'Américain,
Staline s'engage à entrer en guerre contre le Japon,
Trois mois après la capitulation allemande.
Le 11 février, la conférence de Yalta s'achève.
Un vent d'optimisme souffle sur les participants que
Winston Churchill traduit par ses phrases lyriques.
Nous étions tous, comme au sommet d'une colline, en
mesure de contempler enfin à l'infini devant nous,
Les splendeurs des possibilités de l'avenir.
Robert Frank, avant toute chose, pourquoi
cette conférence s'est tenue à Yalta ?
Yalta en Crimée, la Crimée est en Union soviétique et
Staline y tenait. Il ne voulait pas sortir de son pays.
L'idée était de bien faire imprégner les alliés de la façon suivante, c'est l'URSS qui porte le poids de la guerre,
La guerre a lieu sur notre sol, je ne veux pas m'éloigner,
je ne  veux pas m'éloigner du théâtre européen.
Pour Roosevelt, qui était fatigué et malade,
c'était un long voyage ?
Pour Roosevelt, c'est un drame, c'est quand
même 12 000 km, dix jours de voyage,
Il est même passer par Malte où l'a vu Tchang Kaï-chek
en même temps que Churchill.
Il arrive à l'aéroport de Saki. Ensuite, entre 5 et 6h de route cahotantes, il arrive épuisé et surtout il est très malade.
C'est l'ombre de lui-même.
On le voit sur les images qu'il est très amaigri,
Mais malgré cela, on dit beaucoup que l'ambiance a
été très très bonne à Yalta entre les trois grands.
L'ambiance est très bonne. Il y a déjà cette perspective de la victoire, peut-être pas encore dans le Pacifique mais en Europe,
Donc il y a un peu cette euphorie de la victoire à venir.
D'autre part, ce sont ces trois hommes,
ils veulent vraiment s'entendre,
Ça, c'est vraiment le but politique numéro un de chacun des trois.
Donc une ambiance très chaleureuse, je dirais
même une conférence assez arrosée.
Il paraît qu'au niveau des toasts, Churchill et Staline, c'était...
Les taux se multiplient et Churchill et Staline,
on peut leur faire confiance, ils savaient faire,
Le champagne caucasien a coulé vraiment à flots.
Ça c'est important.
Sérieusement, au niveau des résultats de ce
que chacun d'eux obtient d'abord Roosevelt ?
Alors Roosevelt, il obtient la confirmation de l'entrée
en guerre de l'Union soviétique contre le Japon,
Trois mois après la capitulation.
C'était capital, pour lui, c'est capital, il sait qu'il
pourra donc fixer Staline sur la guerre au Pacifique,
Et Staline n'aura pas donc tout à fait les mains libres en Europe.
Bon, Staline ?
Il obtient ça en contrepartie, la contrepartie c'est que
Staline et l'URSS retrouvent un peu leur zone d'influence,
L'époque qu'ils avaient, que la Russie
tsariste avait avant la guerre de 1904-1905.
Deuxième chose qu'obtient Roosevelt, c'est bien sûr l'ONU,
il y avait un désaccord dans les mois qui précédaient,
Les Soviétiques demandaient une représentation à l'ONU,
une voix pour chaque république soviétique socialiste,
Donc quinze plus une voix, quinze ou seize.
Ça faisait beaucoup. Staline était inquiet parce qu'il savait
très bien que l'ONU serait à majorité américaine.
Bon, alors bien sûr les Américains ne voulaient,
Nous avons 48 Etats, pourquoi pas 48 pour nous ?
Et finalement, Roosevelt remporte le morceau. Il y a
un compromis, mais Staline n'obtient que trois voix,
Biélorussie, Ukraine et l'Union soviétique elle-même.
Donc un bon compromis en faveur de Roosevelt,
Et Roosevelt est tout à fait content.
Staline lui obtient satisfaction sur la Pologne,
je crois que c'est le point décisif.
C'est décisif. Je veux dire si on doit faire
le bilan des gains des uns et des autres,
Staline, dans une grande mesure, est le vainqueur
de Yalta et à cause de la Pologne.
En effet, il y avait deux gouvernements en compétition,
le gouvernement de Polonais de Londres,
Le comité de Lublin devenu le gouvernement à Varsovie
qui s'installe à Varsovie, donc plutôt pro-soviétique,
Et disons que le résultat des courses est le suivant,
Un gouvernement d'unité nationale mais où les
pro-soviétiques sont très nettement...
Mais finalement, Staline, il obtient là, à Yalta,
ce que son armée avait obtenu.
Tout à fait. Je veux dire, c'est vrai que de toute
façon, c'était la situation sur le terrain.
Donc à la limite, empêcher Staline d'installer un tel
gouvernement, c'était la guerre, c'était d'essayer de le déloger,
Ce qui était tout à fait impensable alors même
que la guerre n'est pas finie contre les Allemands.
Ce qu'obtient Staline également pour l'Allemagne, c'est
à propos de l'Allemagne, c'est le démembrement,
Il introduit l'idée de démembrer l'Allemagne et en
dernier lieu des réparations, c'est très important.
Grandes discussions sur les réparations. Il obtient
de Roosevelt, Churchill n'est pas d'accord,
Mais c'est inscrit dans le communiqué...
Un engagement de Roosevelt.
20 milliardsde dollars de réparations allemandes pour l'ensemble des bénéficiaires, dont la moitié pour l'Union soviétique,
C'est fondamental pour Staline, donc c'est très très important.
Bon alors la question...
- Reste Churchill, non ?
- Reste Churchill, bien sûr, oui.
Churchill obtient également des choses sur l'Allemagne
et je dirais la chose principale qu'il obtient,
C'est que dans les zones d'occupation déjà
prévues sur l'Allemagne, on passe du chiffre 3 à 4,
En d'autres termes, la France est la principale bénéficiaire
de Yalta, alors même que de Gaulle n'y figure pas,
Je dirais grâce à Churchill, c'est Churchill qui
veut absolument une quatrième zone pour la France,
Que la France occupe un siège également au comité de
contrôle qui va diriger l'Allemagne, pourquoi ?
Pas seulement pour les beaux yeux de la France, c'est
vrai que Churchill est plutôt francophile mais enfin,
Ses rapports avec de Gaulle sont plutôt orageux,
non, c'est pour des raisons, comment dirais-je,
Concernant l'égoïsme national britannique, Churchill
se sent un peu petit face aux deux super grands.
D'autre part, il craint pour l'empire colonial britannique,
avoir une autre puissance coloniale solidaire de l'Angleterre,
Ça donnera plus de poids face à l'Union soviétique
et aux Etats-Unis qui, ensemble sur ce point,
Sont plutôt pour des réformes, voire une décolonisation.
Bon, alors, j'en viens au fameux mythe, premier mythe de
Yalta, à savoir le partage, alors il y a eu partage ou non ?
Il n'y a absolument pas partage à Yalta, deux choses,
Ça a d'abord été une série d'accords sur des points, des points particuliers, comme on l'a vu l'Allemagne, la Pologne, etc.
Deuxièmement, ce qui a été obtenu également
par Roosevelt puisque la Pologne,
Le gouvernement est plutôt dans le sens de ce que voulait
Staline, c'est d'obtenir des élections libres en Pologne,
Et s'y ajoute une déclaration sur l'Europe libérée qui prévoit
des élections libres partout qui seraient contrôlées,
Par tous les alliés ensemble. Bref, l'idée de
gouverner ensemble la gestion de l'après guerre.
Ce qui est bien différent évidemment de l'idée de partage.
Partagé plutôt le gouvernement de l'Europe
plutôt que les territoires.
Voilà, il y a eu un deuxième mythe qui s'est greffé
plus tard, qui lui est de provenance américaine,
Au moment de la guerre froide, on a beaucoup reproché
à Roosevelt d'avoir, fatigué, vieux malade, etc...
D'avoir tout bradé et d'avoir abandonné
finalement tout ce que Staline voulait.
Oui, le premier mythe c'est le mythe du partage,
le deuxième mythe, c'est le mythe du bradage.
Alors Roosevelt a obtenu malgré tout, on l'a vu, certaines
choses, d'autre part, on peut se poser la question,
Qu'est-ce qu'il pouvait obtenir d'autre puisque Staline l'avait déjà, au fond, on pourrait presque inverser la problématique,
Staline avait un gouvernement en Pologne
entièrement pro-soviétique, au fond,
Les Occidentaux obtiennent quelques ministres du gouvernement, ce qui n'est pas beaucoup,
Et surtout, ils se drapent dans les plis du droit. C'est-à-dire, c'est eux qui disent il y a une déclaration sur l'Europe libérée,
Le droit, c'est la démocratie, ce sont les élections
libres, même si elles sont bafouées par Staline,
Le droit sera du côté de l'Occident.
Nous sommes au lendemain de Yalta, mais les trois d'ailleurs
sont assez optimistes mais la guerre n'est pas finie,
Suite des événements.
Deux jours après la conférence de Yalta,
les Anglo-Saxons bombardent la ville de Dresde.
Churchill avait donné des directives à la fin janvier afin
que le bombardement intervienne pendant la conférence.
Il voulait, par cette action d'éclat, impressionner les Russes.
Mais les mauvaises conditions météo retardent l'opération
jusqu'au 13 février. Trop tard pour influencer Staline.
On dénombre 130 000 victimes.
En Roumanie, les communistes qui participent à un gouvernement d'union nationale, revendiquent davantage le pouvoir.
Le 27 février, le jour même où Roosevelt débarque
à New York, de retour de Yalta,
Vychinski, l'ancien procureur des procès de Moscou,
envoyé par Staline arrive à Bucarest.
Un nouveau gouvernement dirigé par Petru Groza où les
communistes détiennent les postes clés est imposé au roi Michel.
Depuis Noël 44, l'Armée rouge marque un
temps d'arrêt devant Budapest.
En février, la conquête de la ville fortifiée et
défendue par 10 000 SS, ce fait maison par maison.
Les soldats soviétiques doivent progresser
par les couloirs du métro.
Après la libération de Budapest, l'Armée rouge poursuit
son avancée vers l'Autriche. Vienne tombe le 13 avril.
À l'Ouest, les Alliés parviennent début mars sur le Rhin,
dont ils contrôlent la rive gauche sur toute la longueur.
Le 7 mars, le fleuve est franchi et une tête de pont consolidée.
Le 23, Churchill en personne a droit au passage du Rhin.
Dès lors, les forces d'Eisenhower pénètrent au cœur de
l'Allemagne hitlérienne mais malgré l'insistance de Churchill,
Ne foncent pas sur Berlin.
La jonction entre GI de la troisième armée et l'avant garde
de l'Armée rouge a lieu le 25 avril à Torgau sur l'Elbe.
Roosevelt ne verra pas cette symbolique et émouvante rencontre.
Frappé par une hémorragie cérébrale, il est mort le 12 avril.
Début avril, les Russes préparent l'assaut final contre Berlin.
1 million d'hommes, 6200 chars, des milliers
d'avions, de pièces d'artillerie sont concentrés,
Pour l'ultime phase de la guerre en Europe.
En face, Hitler ramasse les dernières forces
que Goebbels tente de fanatisées.
L'attaque commence le 12 avril.
Le 22, la capitale du Reich est entièrement
encerclée. Des tonnes d'obus s'abattent sur la ville.
L'armée rouge progresse dans les faubourgs,
rue par rue, au milieu des ruines.
Le 30, le quartier général de la Gestapo tombe, Hitler
se suicide, le drapeau rouge flotte sur Berlin.
Les hostilités vont cesser officiellement,
Ce soir, une minute après minuit.
Ce mardi 8 Mai.
Mais, afin de sauver des vies,
Le cessez le feu a été décrété
hier sur tous les fronts.
La guerre contre
l'Allemagne a pris fin.
Nous pouvons nous accorder une brève période de réjouissance.
Partout, c'est l'euphorie de la victoire.
Il reste à organiser la paix.
Robert Franck, là, nous poursuivons la visite au
Cecilienhof de Potsdam et c'est dans cette pièce même,
Que Churchill et ses conseillers,
pendant la conférence, se réunissaient.
Nous n'en sommes pas encore là dans l'émission parce
que très vite, on s'aperçoit qu'après Yalta,
Les choses se gâtent et notamment que Staline ne
respecte pas les accords qui sont passés à Yalta.
Quelques jours après la conférence de Yalta, en février,
l'Union soviétique installe en Roumanie et en Bulgarie,
Des gouvernements où les communistes jouent un rôle clé.
Or, il le fait sans consultation des alliés.
Alors, bien sûr, on pourrait toujours dire qu'il
le fait en fonction des accords des pourcentages,
Qu'il a signés avec Churchill en octobre 44, enfin
qu'il a signé, qu'ils ont conclu oralement.
Mais en fait, Yalta était en contradiction avec
ces accords. Yalta était la dernière décision.
On peut donc dire qu'il viole les accords
de Yalta et la lettre et l'esprit.
À ce moment là, comment réagit Roosevelt ?
Roosevelt réagit mal. Roosevelt est très
malade, on le sait, il réagit mal,
Et on peut dire que son dernier message
est un message de fermeté. Il est furieux.
Un message de fermeté, c'est-à-dire ?
Un message de fermeté, je veux dire par là, il le
dit à Churchill et il le dit à ceux qui le conseil,
Il faut que nous restions fermes à l'égard des Russes.
Et alors son successeur, Truman, prend quelle attitude ?
Roosevelt meurt le 12 avril et Truman a une attitude
relativement hésitante, une chose que ne voit pas Roosevelt,
C'est bien sûr la victoire, donc l'avancée
des troupes anglo-américaines vers l'est.
De ce point de vue, Truman a l'attitude suivante,
Les Britanniques demandent d'aller le plus loin possible vers l'Est, puisque Staline a violé Yalta, il n'y a pas de raison,
Truman préfère l'attitude conciliante et il respecte les accords
de Yalta et la façon dont ont été divisées les zones d'occupation.
Une fois la victoire obtenue en Europe contre Hitler,
là, il en vient peut-être à une mesure de fermeté,
Ou en tout cas un signal contre Staline,
il suspend la loi prêt-bail.
C'est-à-dire ?
C'est-à-dire qu'il suspend l'aide financière aux alliés en général.
Et Staline le prend assez mal.
Il le prend très mal, si mal que Truman revient sur
sa décision. Donc il y a une hésitation de Truman.
Alors il y en a un, évidemment, qui s'inquiètent beaucoup de
ce qui se passe dans l'est de l'Europe, c'est Churchill,
Parce qu'il y a quand même ce télégramme extrêmement prémonitoire, étonnant, du 12 mai 45, quatre jours après la victoire,
Où il parle du rideau de fer qui s'est abattu sur
le front soviétique, Churchill est très inquiet.
Churchill est inquiet. Il invente donc cette expression le
rideau de fer. Le télégramme, bien sûr, reste secret.
Le public ne connaîtra cette expression qu'une année plus tard,
Lorsqu'il dira en public pendant son discours de Fulton,
aux États-Unis mais cela montre bien son d'inquiétude,
Cela montre aussi à quel point il voit le jeu de
Staline et il pense qu'il faut effectivement réagir,
Et il est pour une politique de fermeté.
Bon, là, on a vu tous les côtés négatifs de l'après Yalta,
mais il y a quand même des points positifs ?
Oui, il y a certains points de Yalta qui sont malgré
tout appliqués dans les mois qui suivent,
Surtout, et là Roosevelt ne voit pas son œuvre se faire, quelques jours après sa mort s'ouvre la conférence de San Francisco,
Pendant laquelle 50 pays vont discuter de la charte, sur la base des accords de Yalta et la charte sera signée le 28 juin 1945,
Et c'est là que se met en place donc en
particulier, non seulement l'assemblée générale,
Mais on prévoit ce Conseil de sécurité avec cinq membres permanents donc les fameux gendarmes de Roosevelt sont devenus cinq.
France, Chine, plus les trois grands donc il
y a là une sorte de triomphe posthume.
Et sur la Pologne ?
Et en même temps, ça a été très long. L'accord de Yalta concernant la Pologne a donné lieu à des discussions entre Polonais,
Et ça y est, c'est chose faite, en fin juin est
mis en place un gouvernement d'unité nationale,
Où effectivement les communistes et les pro-soviétiques
ont les principaux postes, ils sont même majoritaires,
Et quelques strapontins pour les Polonais,
c'est une victoire pour Staline.
Bon, et de toutes ces tensions, il né la nécessité de se
revoir donc nécessité d'une nouvelle conférence à Potsdam,
Et d'ailleurs là, en marchant, nous sommes venus à Potsdam,
dans la salle où se réunissaient la délégation américaine,
Et le président Truman, maintenant Potsdam.
Le physicien Robert Oppenheimer, directeur du Centre de recherche de Los Alamos, est chargé de mener à bien le projet Manhattan,
C'est-à-dire la fabrication de la bombe atomique.
Au début de juillet 45, il effectue avec son
équipe les dernières mises au point.
Le nouveau président américain Harry Truman n'a pas
une grande expérience des affaires internationales,
Lorsqu'il succède à Roosevelt.
Cet ancien propriétaire d'un magasin de confection est un homme modeste et simple, plus attiré par l'action que par les idées.
Le 15 juillet 45, Harry Truman atterrit à
Berlin où il est accueilli par Gromyko.
La conférence entre les trois grands doit
s'ouvrir deux jours plus tard à Potsdam,
Petite ville à une vingtaine de kilomètres de Berlin.
En attendant Staline malade, Truman et Churchill
parcourt Berlin, dont il ne reste pas grand chose.
C'est la première fois que le Premier ministre
anglais rencontre le président des Etats-Unis.
Il note dans ses mémoires qu'il est impressionné par
la gaieté de Truman, sa précision, sa vivacité,
Et son évidente puissance de décision.
À Los Alamos, Oppenheimer est prêt.
C'est dans la soirée du 16 juillet que Truman apprend
que la première bombe atomique de l'histoire,
A explosé dans le désert du Nouveau-Mexique.
L'expérience est un succès complet.
Le lendemain, 17 juillet, s'ouvre la conférence de Potsdam. Straumann hérite de la présidence de la première session.
Staline abandonne l'idée d'un démembrement de l'Allemagne,
mais exige, devant l'ampleur des destructions dans son pays,
D'énormes dommages de guerre sur la base
de ce qui avait été envisagé à Yalta.
Les Occidentaux estiment qu'une somme aussi
importante ne peut être payée par l'Allemagne ruinée.
Un autre litige porte sur la frontière
entre la Pologne et l'Allemagne.
Pendant des jours, la conférence s'enlise
dans d'interminables négociations.
Le 24 juillet, à la fin d'une séance particulièrement
houleuse, Truman annonce à Staline que les Américains,
Sont en possession d'une arme nouvelle.
Le premier Russe ne manifesta aucun intérêt
particulier, note Truman dans ses mémoires.
Tout ce qu'il dit, c'est qu'il était
content d'apprendre cette bonne nouvelle,
Et qu'il espérait que nous en ferions bon usage contre le Japon.
En fait, grâce à ses espions, Staline
n'ignore rien du projet Manhattan.
Le 25, Churchill s'envole pour Londres afin de
participer aux élections. Il ne reviendra pas.
Les conservateurs sont battus et c'est
Clément Attlee, le leader travailliste,
Qui remplace le vieux lion autour de la table de négociations.
Le 30 juillet, pour débloquer la situation, le secrétaire
d'Etat américain Byrnes, propose un package deal,
C'est-à-dire un compromis global sur tous les sujets
en litige. Compromis finalement accepté par tous.
À Potsdam, pas plus qu'à Yalta, il n'est question
autour de la table de se partager l'Europe.
Mais à Potsdam, on constate la division du continent issu des combats. Déjà, on pressens que les zones d'occupation militaire,
Vont se transformer en zone d'influence. Staline obtient sur le tapis vert ce que l'Armée rouge avait conquis sur le terrain,
La carte de l'Europe future n'est pas tracée à
Potsdam. Elle a été dessinée par la force des armes,
Et les rêves idéalistes se fracasseront sur cette réalité.
Enfin, Truman obtient de Staline la confirmation
de l'entrée en guerre contre le Japon le 8 août.
Dans le Pacifique, en effet, les combats sont
acharnés. La flotte américaine subit en particulier,
Les dégâts causés par les raids suicides des kamikazes.
Les experts américains évaluent à un an le temps
nécessaire pour venir à bout de la résistance nippone,
Et à au moins un demi million le nombre des victimes américaines.
Le 26 juillet 45, Truman, dans une proclamation, exhorte le gouvernement japonais à une reddition inconditionnelle.
Sinon, ajoute le texte, l'alternative, c'est pour le
Japon une destruction imminente et complète.
Il y a peu de temps,
un avion américain,
A largué une bombe sur Hiroshima.
La ville est totalement anéantie.
Cette bome est plus puissante
que 20 000 tonnes de TNT.
Le 8 août, comme prévu, l'URSS déclare la guerre au
Japon et les troupes soviétiques entrent en Mandchourie.
Le lendemain, 9 août, une deuxième bombe est larguée sur Nagasaki.
Le 15 août, l'empereur Hirohito annonce au monde la capitulation
du Japon. La Deuxième Guerre mondiale est terminée.
Nous sommes donc là, dans la fameuse salle où s'est tenue la conférence de Potsdam. Là, je suis appuyé sur le siège de Staline,
Là, c'était le président Truman et là c'était
Churchill et puis après, il a été remplacé par Attlee.
Alors, est-ce que le changement des têtes
par rapport à Yalta a changé l'ambiance ?
Changement des têtes, bon Truman à la place de Franklin
Roosevelt qui était à Yalta, c'est évidemment un changement,
L'homme est moins expérimenté. Byrnes, le secrétaire
d'État, joue un très grand rôle à Potsdam.
C'est l'équivalent du ministre des Affaires
étrangères et il joue un rôle fondamental.
Quand je parlais de l'ambiance, c'était les relations
entre les hommes, ça n'empêche pas Churchill de boire ?
Non, et Staline non plus. Je veux dire, ils se retrouvent.
Les toasts continuent, l'ambiance n'est pas du tout la même
qu'à Yalta. Il n'y a pas cette cordialité, cette chaleur,
Mais il y a des moments de cordialité. Il ne
faut pas non plus de tout voir en noir.
Evidemment, l'événement considérable qu'on apprend tout au début de la conférence, c'est que les Américains ont l'arme atomique,
Et ça, ça va tout bouleverser.
La conférence commence le 17 juillet, or,
la veille, le 16 juillet, Truman est déjà à Potsdam,
Il vient d'apprendre la réussite de l'explosion de la
bombe atomique dans le désert du Nouveau-Mexique.
C'est évident que ça change tout. Ça change tout, ça change
le rapport des forces, on peut dire en deux mots,
À Yalta, la première armée du monde, c'est
l'armée soviétique, c'est l'Armée rouge.
À Potsdam, la première puissance militaire du monde, c'est évidemment l'Amérique, les Etats-Unis grâce à cette bombe.
Alors les grandes questions en litige qui
sont en discutées, ici à Potsdam,
Il y a évidemment la question polonaise
qui est au centre des discussions.
La question polonaise et la question allemande.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'il reste de la question polonaise ?
La question du gouvernement était réglée à
Yalta, reste la question des frontières.
Staline veut que la frontière entre la Pologne et l'Allemagne
soit celle de l'Oder-Neisse, la Neisse occidentale,
Donc plus de territoires pour les Polonais. Et bien sûr le nouveau gouvernement polonais est tout à fait d'accord avec Staline.
Les occidentaux veulent l'autre Neisse, la Neisse
orientale, donc moins de territoire aux Polonais.
L'autre litige, ce sont les réparations.
Staline tient à ces réparations. Il a deux objectifs, la
sécurité de son pays mais aussi la reconstruction de son pays.
Il demande beaucoup d'argent, 20 milliardsde dollars.
C'est ce qu'il a obtenu de Roosevelt à Yalta et, là, visiblement les Britanniques qui n'étaient pas d'accord à Yalta,
Mais même Truman et Byrnes lui contestent ces 20 milliards. Et là, Staline n'est pas content. Ah ça, il le fait comprendre.
Byrnes joue un rôle important, il est très habile, il fait ce package deal, c'est-à-dire une sorte de troc au fond,
C'est-à-dire que sur la question polonaise,
il donne plutôt satisfaction à Staline,
En effet donc la ligne au Oder-Neisse oriental, pardon occidental ! Mais il est spécifié que cette ligne est provisoire,
Jusqu'au règlement définitif de la paix.
Provisoire a duré un demi siècle et qu'il dure toujours.
Il dure toujours et ça n'a jamais été remis en question.
Donc là, il y a satisfaction finalement pour Staline, en revanche, pour les réparations, il n'est plus question des 20 milliards,
Et en gros les Soviétiques doivent se servir sur leur propre...
Self service sur le territoire.
Self service sur le territoire avec 10% de
livraisons qui viendront de l'ouest.
Alors évidemment, le grand point, c'est la question :
qu'advient-il de l'Allemagne ?
Puisque pendant très longtemps, il était question entre les grandes d'un démembrement et que là, à Potsdam, il n'en est plus question.
Il y a une différence, à Yalta, on a dit démembrement,
à Potsdam, on revient à une unité de l'Allemagne,
Une Allemagne qui serait gouvernée par les grands alliés ensemble. Par les quatre, les trois plus un, le quatrième étant la France.
Il y a donc un changement de la part de Staline.
C'est lui qui a demandé le démembrement à Yalta
et qui demande maintenant plutôt l'unité.
Alors on a l'impression, c'est ça qui est intéressant,
c'est qu'il a peut-être deux fers au feu,
Il hésite entre deux lignes. Est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
gouverner avec les occidentaux toute l'Allemagne ensemble,
D'où une influence soviétique diffuse mais
jusqu'au Rhin, jusqu'à la frontière française,
Ou bien, alors effectivement, jouer contre l'esprit
de Yalta, jouer la division, comment dirais-je,
Être beaucoup plus ferme sur un plan idéologique
et établir pourquoi pas le communisme,
Mais uniquement sur une partie de l'Allemagne et dans ce cas une influence plus concentrée, mais jusqu'à l'Elbe seulement.
Et il hésite encore et disons qu'à Potsdam, il joue plutôt l'esprit de Yalta, c'est à dire gouverner ensemble l'Allemagne.
Justement, on voit bien que, pas plus à Postdam qu'à Yalta, qu'il y a une vraie division de l'Europe sur le tapis rouge d'ailleurs,
Ici, mais quand même, s'opère déjà en germe la division
future de l'Europe. Qu'est-ce qui dicte cette division ?
Je crois que cette division, c'est un processus,
un long processus qui a commencé avant Yalta.
Yalta n'a pas réussi à l'enrayer et qui se termine véritablement qu'avec la crise de Berlin, la première crise de Berlin de 48-49.
La guerre froide et bloc contre bloc ce n'était
pas absolument inscrit dans ces conférences.
Ce n'était pas vraiment inscrit, la division commence à
montrer le bout du nez. Mais d'autres signes montrent que,
On l'a vu pour l'Allemagne, il y a peut-être
une certaine velléité de gouverner ensemble.
En tout cas, Staline veut gagner du temps.
Je crois qu'il compte sur ces réparations,
Donc il veut jouer le jeu de l'esprit de Yalta pour
avoir une chance de recevoir une aide américaine,
Ou en tout cas une aide par l'intermédiaire des réparations allemandes. Je répète, la reconstruction de son pays,
La reconstruction de l'URSS, c'est un enjeu fondamental pour
lui et on peut dire au fond, il a encore le choix,
Il dit au fond, jouer l'esprit de Yalta, c'est
avoir une influence malgré tout en Europe,
Une aide occidentale qui permettra la reconstruction de l'URSS et pourquoi pas, aller plus vite dans le processus du socialisme.
En revanche, rompre avec eux, ça veut dire choisir
la pauvreté. C'est ce qui finalement, il le fera.
Mais bon, est-ce que c'était le bon choix ?
Alors l'événement majeur qui intervient
évidemment, c'est Hiroshima,
Parce que là, on entre dans une
autre ère de relation internationale.
Quelques jours après Potsdam. Et c'est ça qui va finalement déterminer cet équilibre des forces de la terreur,
Qui va déterminer les relations internationales
pendant le demi siècle qui suit.
Alors l'équilibre des forces, pas tout de suite.
Il faut attendre 49 pour la bombe soviétique,
L'équilibre lui même à partir de la fin des années 50.
Mais c'est vrai, ça change complètement
les données en relations internationales.
Et Yalta, Potsdam, montre bien l'émergence de deux géants.
Ce sont ces deux géants, là l'angleterre compte peu,
La France non plus, qui d'ailleurs est absente.
...de l'après guerre, dominée par l'affrontement entre les Américains et l'Union soviétique, là est en germe à ce moment là.
Ce monde bipolaire est en germe à ce moment là, c'est
évident et même si les processus de division de l'Europe,
N'est pas encore complètement terminé, en revanche, le règne
des deux super grands est déjà dès Yalta, dès Potsdam.
Alors comment vous expliquez en historien que le
mythe de Yalta ait perduré et perdure toujours,
C'est-à-dire qu'on continue à croire que, de Yalta à
Potsdam, les grands se sont partagés l'Europe,
Autour de la table alors que ce n'est pas ça, on
vient de le voir tout au long de cette émission.
Si on prend le mythe lancé par le général de Gaulle,
à savoir le partage des trois grands,
Je crois qu'il y a plusieurs choses à dire, c'est vrai qu'après tout, les trois grands ont quand même décidé du sort du monde,
De beaucoup de questions entre eux. Donc ça,
je trouve que c'est assez impressionnant.
Deuxièmement, ce processus que je vous ai décrit, c'est quand même compliqué, un processus qui commence en 44 qui se termine en 49,
La guerre froide ayant commencé en 47, alors que le mot
de Yalta, cinq lettres qui claque comme un fouet,
C'est quand même beaucoup plus simple, comme explication.
Je crois que là aussi, il y a cet aspect là.
Du côté français, il y peut être un autre aspect,
c'est au fond une sorte de complexe de la France,
Qui n'a pas participé à cette conférence, ni à Yalta, ni à
Potsdam, c'est-à-dire, au fond, une blessure, la blessure,
La France n'est plus ce qu'elle était et le regard des
autres sur la France, au fond, si la France est absente,
C'est parce qu'elle ne s'est pas battue autant que les autres.
Et là, je crois que c'est très important, Vichy, l'occupation,
La défaite, c'est une blessure importante. Et Yalta est
un peu la consécration de la dégradation de la France,
Au fond, lorsqu'on donne une zone d'occupation à la France, Staline avait dit Bon, oui, pourquoi pas mais pourquoi pas la Pologne ?
Il y a au moins autant de soldats polonais
dans la guerre que de soldats français,
Donc la France n'est plus une grande puissance, c'est évident.
Et alors, après un demi siècle, quel est le regard de l'historien finalement sur sur cette fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale ?
Le vainqueur des trois, c'est qui ?
Si on parle des trois grands, à titre posthume, ce
n'est pas Churchill, ni Attlee les vainqueurs.
L'Empire britannique, que défendait Churchill
en tout cas, n'existe plus.
Fin de cette puissance là.
Staline, l'URSS n'est plus. Donc, à titre
posthume, c'est finalement l'idéaliste,
C'est Franklin Roosevelt qui est le vainqueur.
Au fond, il voulait un monde gouverné par
des gendarmes, les Etats-Unis sont bien là,
La puissance américaine est encore là aujourd'hui, c'est le principal gendarme du monde incontesté par le biais de l'ONU,
Pour le meilleur et pour le pire. Mais la puissance
américaine est encore intacte 50 ans plus tard.
Et au fond, Roosevelt voulait que cette puissance américaine joua le rôle principal sur la scène internationale,
Sorte de l'isolationnisme, de ce point de vue, il a réussi.
Voilà. Alors pour terminer cette émission ici à Potsdam,
quelques livres qui, sur la question, il y en a énormément,
De Yalta à Potsdam, des illusions à la guerre froide, un très bon livre d'Artur Funk, qui parut chez les Editions Complexe,
- On peut le recommander ?
- Tout à fait.
Le classique André Fontaine, l'histoire de la guerre froide,
dont une partie porte évidemment sur ce moment là,
Et d'ailleurs, sur la couverture de ce livre, on voit la
célèbre poignée de main entre Staline, Churchill et Truman,
Qui s'est déroulée ici.
Daniel Yergin, La paix saccagée, Editions
Complexe aussi un bon bouquin.
Très bon livre, intéressant à lire, qui donne
des interprétations tout à fait suggestives.
Sur les origines de la guerre froide, la division de
l'Europe. Alors, le livre d'un diplomate, Jean Laloy,
Qui a accompagné le général de Gaulle en décembre 44 à Moscou, Yalta hier, aujourd'hui, demain, paru chez Robert Laffont,
Il y a 7, 8 ans, je crois.
Là c'est un livre manuel pour les étudiants, vous pouvez peut-être en dire un mot, puisque vous y avez participé chez Masson,
La loi des géants 41-64, avec René Giraud et
Jacques Thobie. Alors Robert Frank, c'est ?
Rien à dire spécialement.
Rien à dire, bon on le recommande quand même. Là qui vient de sortir, excellent, édition La Découverte, l'État du monde en 1945,
Sous la direction de Stéphane Courtois,
Annette Wieviorka, une multitude de petits articles,
Sur tout ce qui se passe dans le monde en 45. Excellent.
C'est très très bien.
Très très bien fait et vraiment pour travailler, formidable.
Alors la documentation Française a sorti des dossiers
et là c'est le dossier sur Hiroshima la bombe,
Avec les unes des journaux de l'époque.
C'est une très bonne idée je trouve, malheureusement ça
ne continue plus, mais c'était une très bonne idée.
Envie d'aller un peu plus loin, il y a les Mémoires de Winston Churchill, paru chez Plon, il y a un certain nombre d'années,
Et là, c'est le tome six Triomphe et tragédie,
ça s'appelle Le Rideau de fer,
Et qui raconte évidemment du 4 février 45 au 26 juillet 45,
donc c'est justement la période dont on a parlé,
Tout au long de cette émission, tout à fait passionnant. L'histoire vécue de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale qui paraît en dix volumes,
Avec une multitude, une très très belle
iconographie des cartes est très très utile.
Et enfin, je signale que Le Monde vient de publier
L'histoire au jour le jour, la guerre froide 44-94,
Un recueil d'articles publiés dans Le Monde. Voilà,
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui. Dans un mois exactement,
Les brûlures de l'histoire seront consacrées
à l'élection présidentielle de 1965,
De Gaulle et Mitterrand ou Mitterrand contre de Gaulle. Les
secrets d'une élection, les secrets d'un ballotage. Bonsoir !